(audience applauding)
- Welcome to "The Kelly
Clarkson Show," everybody.
I know what you're possibly
thinking right now.
Why is there an audience in the studio
and I am here in the monitor?
'Tis the season to spend a little time
home for the holidays.
♪ Home for the holidays ♪
(audience applauding)
(Kelly chuckling)
- Get it, Jess.
So, I don't really want
to be at home right now.
I'm actually here getting over COVID,
which, well, sucks.
It's the worst.
So, (chuckling)
but I'm feeling better
and I could not miss this show.
I am such a fan (giggling)
of this person that's
about to start this show,
so, even not feeling well, I showed up,
because the show must
go on and I love her.
So, as always,
(audience cheering)
we are gonna kick things off
first, though, with some music.
This is a fun Kellyoke
encore of me, Jimmy Fallon,
and my band, Y'all, doing
"I've Got You Babe."
That's how we're starting.
(audience cheering)
♪ They say we're young and we don't know ♪
♪ We won't find out until we grow ♪
♪ Well, I don't know if all that's true ♪
♪ You got me and baby I got you ♪
♪ Babe ♪
♪ I got you, babe ♪
♪ They say our love won't pay the rent ♪
♪ Before it's earned, our
money's all been spent ♪
♪ I guess that's so, we don't have a pot ♪
♪ But at least I'm sure
of all the things we got ♪
♪ Babe ♪
♪ I got you, babe ♪
♪ So let them say your hair's too long ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't care,
with you I can't go wrong ♪
♪ Then put your tiny little hand in mine ♪
♪ There ain't no hill or
mountain we can't climb ♪
That's right!
♪ I got you to hold my hand ♪
♪ I got you to understand ♪
♪ I got you to walk with me ♪
♪ I got you to talk with me ♪
♪ I got you to kiss goodnight ♪
♪ I got you to hold me tight ♪
♪ I got you, I won't let go ♪
♪ I got you to love me so ♪
♪ I got you, babe ♪
(audience cheering)
One more time, give it up
for Jimmy Fallon, y'all.
My band, Y'all.
(audience applauding)
Oh, it's so fun.